your father of course Clint Eastwood and
I just wanted to mention it's gotta be
strange because I would think okay this
is your dad who again clinched his name
is Clint Eastwood oh yeah yeah yeah that
guy and and what's interesting to me is
that I learned that you have to audition
for his movies well seems weird to me
because you'd think he'd know what you
can do what you can't do
yeah no no he does not he does not I
think he likes me in his movies you know
because here's the thing he's he's put
me in a few movies and I've auditioned
for a lot and haven't got a lot and then
Gran Torino came around where he was
talking to me was like this little role
yeah and you've got a supposed to his
character is supposed to be giving you a
character hard time yeah yeah exactly
it's calling me a [ __ ] and you know you
know spoiled little brat or whatever and
so he gave me that role and on the day
we were shooting it there's a lot of
stuff that came out that wasn't on the
script there that that wasn't in the
script right right okay yeah and so they
make me think like he's working through
some issues yeah hard for the kid get in
this part the part right chew out that
punk I think there's a lot of pent up
over the years of me pissing him off
yeah you pissing him off maybe that's a
healthy way you know that's a good kind
of therapy yeah
you